I think Graham Steffen is totally wrong
about gurus on the internet and the
business of selling courses and I want
to tell you why but let me start by
saying Graham is kind of a YouTube gym
he teaches financial success and talks
openly about his real estate business
you know all things related to money
from what I can tell he's a really
honest guy genuine guy he's got a lot of
great value to bring but that's a video
for another time what I want to focus on
right now is that Graham Stefan and I
have two competing visions of what a
fake guru is and he's got a video called
took that has the keyword fake guru so I
know people see that video when they're
looking at my video and I want to
challenge his idea of fake gurus because
I think he has a way of thinking about
gurus that will keep you on the Guru
treadmill which I see people on a lot
right they comment on my videos hey
thanks for calling out X now I'm gonna
go to why you know it's the same guy
doing the same sales pitch except
because I haven't called him out they
feel like well maybe this is the real
guru and my point to you guys is that if
they're selling a two thousand dollar
course and they're advertising it it's
probably a scam a gram would tell you
well there's some sleazy people there's
some legit people he doesn't really say
the mix it seems like he's saying that
for everyone sleazy guy you're gonna
have an honest broker for every sleazy
fly-by-night snake oil salesman out
there is someone who understands the
business model and who takes an honest
customer oriented approach to business
but that's not true of the info sales
industry and I want to tell you why
today I think that it's actually
completely different I think every time
a sleazy salesman will out-compete an
honest salesman if given no regulation
on the industry which currently we
really don't have much regulation so
let's start with Graham's view of gurus
before we get into why I disagree with
it
Graham would tell you and you can watch
his video I'll link it down below his
video essentially says this I used to
not think the info sales world was legit
I thought you it was dishonest to you
know sell information that's available
for free online
I was vehemently against selling
anything online but then I realized that
not all information products have to be
win-lose
but hear me out on this one the
distinction I wasn't aware of before
selling information is that selling
information did not need to be a
win-lose transaction and that ultimately
what gives the industry a bad name is
just the sleazy fly-by-night salesmen
and these types of sleazy fly-by-night
snake oil salesmen give everyone else
the negative connotation of being a scam
you know it's kind of a few bad apples
situation where the bad apples give the
rest of us a bad image and so what is
Graham's formula for what makes a sleazy
fly-by-night snake oil salesman versus a
legit person who's selling information
well the biggest difference I see
between the sleazy salesman and the
honest influencer is just the desire to
bring long-term value from a
consumer-oriented perspective someone
who gives more information I guess he
doesn't really define value but I guess
that means like gives more than you paid
for it's sort of the idea so when you
think of selling information in these
terms and you think of the customer
experience first all of a sudden I can
scale up and it becomes a win-win
scenario for everybody involved but this
is where we get into trouble okay
we get into trouble here because he I
feel like it's because he didn't define
value that we have a problem when you
buy a product you're not looking for the
abstract idea of value you're looking to
get what you were promised when you
bought it right you were if I go to a
doctor and I say hey how much is my leg
surgery gonna be and he says it's gonna
be 500 bucks and I say great hidden 500
bucks and he gives me a two hour long
seminar on real estate investing I may
have gotten a lot of value but that
doesn't mean anything
to my leg and I don't care at this point
because I didn't want a real estate
seminar I wanted my leg to be healed
right so what I want to propose to you
is a totally different definition that
will change the way you think about
Gruber's if a guru is simply someone who
promises something that you do not get
when you buy the course and I'm gonna
argue to you guys today though very
business framework of faith gurus mean
that you're not going to succeed unless
you promise more than you give okay
and I'm gonna get into why because
Graham will tell you look what is
revolutionized the information sales
industry is the ability to scale right
instead of me being in a class and only
being able to teach thirty students now
I can make videos and sell them to
thirty thousand students right that's
the that's the scalable formula so he
says look the winning formula is to
ultimately convert cold leads and when
you find the winning formula to convert
a cold audience and turn eyeballs into
dollars what that means in advertising
is you take someone who's never seen
your face before you run an ad on them
right and you make more money from
people who don't know you buying your
product than you do from spending money
that's that's what he means by convert
cold leads to turn eyeballs into dollars
but that formula that winning formula
he's talking about we know what that is
because we know who's winning who is
winning in the Guru business well Dan
Locke's winning right Dan Locke made ten
million dollars lessons in information
products we know that Kevin David is
when he came to he won't admit he got
ten million dollars we know that Sam
Evans is winning right and what do these
guys promise you what are these what are
they actually selling what are you
buying when you pay for their product
what should you be expecting in value as
grant would say well I I'll show you
Kevin David says this sorry guys forgot
copyright Kevin's gonna trade me if I if
I show you his actual video even though
it's fair you so instead I'll just read
you what he says on his his webinar page
he goes how to create a full-time income
with no experience and zero money to
start using the map strategy Allah says
this I'm gonna give you undeniable proof
how you can make forty thousand dollars
to two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year with nothing more than a
computer a phone using skills you can
learn in a weekend and Sam Ivan says the
I'm gonna show you how you can start
your very own wildly profitable
consulting business from scratch and
then actually get clients be able to
provide value to them and get paid in
return and I'm gonna show you how to do
all of this regardless of the experience
that you have the skills that you have
so these gurus are all pitching the same
thing even though they have all have a
different way of talking about it one
says I want to pitch you Amazon FBA one
says I want to make you a high ticket
closer one says I want to teach you
consulting but the point is the way you
actually convert on cold leads is by
selling not information but you sell a
dream of financial independence that's
how you actually succeed and the problem
is is you cannot make those promises
these people are not providing enough
value we've seen so many testimonials of
people who've taken the course applied
the concepts that maybe are useful maybe
they're useful concepts but they're not
what they were buying they're not
they're not a formula for becoming rich
quick which is what a lot of these guys
sell this is not this is a fantasy it's
smoke it's not real but this is the
winning formula he's talking about when
he talks about converting cold leads how
to create a full-time income with no
experience two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year using skills you
can learn in a weekend wildly profitable
consulting business from scratch
regardless of the experience that you
have the skills that you have because
the truth is running an ad on a cold
lead if you're being honest will never
convert enough saying hey yeah actually
this course doesn't work for a lot of
you a lot of you are gonna lose money on
this course yeah and actually
entrepreneurship is hard and a lot of
you should keep your job and you know
what a very small minority of you are
gonna make it you should have a really
high tip risk tolerance and there's
literally nothing I can promise you
because the results are all over the map
saying that you're not gonna buy a two
thousand dollar course for me but if I
go to you and I say hey by my two
thousand dollar course you'll get a
proven roadmap to success baby this
exact now you're all of a sudden buyer
for me now I got two thousand dollars in
my pocket so I think Graham is
mentally wrong when he thinks like there
are just some bad apples few bad apples
to give the rest of us a bad name know
the the information sales industry is
fundamentally skewed towards the bad
apples because the bad apples just sell
a lot better they scale a lot faster
than being honest false advertising
unregulated always wins which is why it
needs to be called out for what it is
that we need to address the problem
which is not value it's not a value
problem all these gurus they have they
have a course they have a bunch of
videos in the course the problem is is
that they're promising something they
don't deliver on and that's what we need
to address in the Guru industry and
frankly I think that starts with these
gurus getting a reputation and the only
way gurus fake gurus versus real gurus
they can separate themselves distinguish
themselves is if the reputation sticks
but right now we're in an environment
where the copyright keven's of the world
will falsely take down your video to
prevent that reputation from sticking
we're in an environment where none of
the gurus the honest gurus want to stand
up and call out the people they know are
scams because they just want to get
along they just want to get along with
every kumbaya what's up you guys it's
Graham here so I'm here with a few
pretty special guests that cancel it
you're doing one scam artist is what
we're saying dude mostly shop fight
affiliate marketing jobs are being
ecommerce Facebook guides it's fraud my
name is Kevin David so I started out
with Amazon FBA that's kind of like
where I began this whole journey where
they are telling you that their business
model is to lie so what they told you
and it's preventing these guys from
getting exposed and the real gurus from
being able to you know sell honestly the
other problem is of course that really
really I don't want to put the burden on
you know keep youtubers to do this to
self-police I really think the FTC
should be involved their problem is the
FTC is really underfunded it's like more
underfunded than in the Reagan
administration so that DC isn't gonna do
anything so in the meantime it's up to
this industry to sort of self-regulate
which is kind of sad because nobody
wants to do it nobody wants to be sort
of the bad guy that talks bad about
other
but but the truth is is if you're legit
you've got to you've got to stand up and
say something you guys which is why I
appreciate all the testimonials coming
out you know saying you know I lost
thirteen thousand dollars from these
guys you know I am a real seller and
this guy's falsely advertising you know
Pete this stuff needs to come out and
it's not gonna come out when we're just
kind of pretending like oh it's just a
couple bad apples here and there and you
know scammers are sort of inevitable
which is something Graham says
fly-by-night snake oil salesmen are
unavoidable in any single business they
will always be there and I agree
generally like yeah scammers are
inevitable in every industry but this is
a unique industry because the scammers
are so prevalent and they're so
unregulated that they are out competing
the real gurus people ask me for the
real gurus I say I don't know where to
find him cuz everybody who's running ads
right now they're fake gurus because
that's what sells why would I go to
somebody who's saying oh yeah this is a
super risky investment you probably not
gonna succeed little of the law which is
true versus the guy says I have a proven
track record winning formula blah blah
blah scam or BS anyway that's my
disagreement with Graham I think Graham
is great guy you should go subscribe to
him I'll link his channel below but on
the Guru's guy's leave it to Sifu okay
leave it to the fake guru King to call
him out because this idea that oh yeah
it's just a couple of bad apples you
know scammers get get you know they'll
eventually weed themselves out it's just
not true
I mean Herbalife's been around for
decades and whey's been around for
decades
there are many scams look bad scammers
get caught
bad scammers weed themselves out but if
you're sophisticated and you know oh I
can just sue people who disagree with me
I have a bunch of money so I can
outspend everybody else who's being
honest I think you can have a very long
lifespan in an environment that doesn't
call these guys out so guys that's
that's my little pitch on gurus I I just
need the coffee Zilla vision of gurus to
dominate because I think it's so
clear-cut in this industry the
something needs to change the industry
needs to get cleaned up and that's only
gonna happen when people realize that
actually the number of people who are
predatory and we're scamming in this
industry is abnormal it's not just like
oh well I guess in every industry you
know there's gonna be some scammers no
there's a weird amount of scammers in
this industry and it's for the reason of
you know it's just false advertising
wins it wins when you don't call it up
so that's it thanks for watching guys
I'll see ya soon I guess I've been
making a lot of these videos recently
and having fun with it guys been having
a lot of fun with it so see you soon
[Music]
[Music]